♪ ♪
>> Tucker: WE HAVE LEARNED
RECENTLY FROM THE "ATLANTIC"
MAGAZINE WHICH WAS A NEW
EXPERIENCE BECAUSE WE DON'T
USUALLY LEARN THINGS FROM THE
ATLANTIC BUT WE LEARNED THAT
KAMALA HARRIS MAINTAINS AN
ENEMIES LIST, JOURNALISTS WHO
MAKE HER MAD.
HERE IS, POLITICO REPORTED,
DRAGS POLITICAL PLAYERS AND
REPORT IS WHO SHE THINKS DON'T
FULLY UNDERSTAND OR APPRECIATE
HER LIFE EXPERIENCE.
HER LIFE EXPERIENCE, LIKE
GROWING UP IN CANADA?
THAT IS LIFE EXPERIENCE SHE
DOESN'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT.
NOTHING MAKES HER ANGRIER THAN
WHEN PEOPLE QUESTION HER LIVED
EXPERIENCE, WHICH IS A EUPHEMISM
FOR HER UNSUPPORTED OPINIONS.
VISITING THE SOUTHERN BORDER IN
MEXICO BACK IN JUNE, ONE NBC
REPORTER FOUND THAT OUT THE HARD
WAY.
>> DO YOU HAVE ANY PLANS TO
VISIT THE BORDER?
>> AT SOME POINT -- WE ARE GOING
TO THE BORDER, WE'VE BEEN TO THE
BORDER, SO THIS WHOLE THING
ABOUT THE BORDER, WE'VE BEEN TO
THE BORDER.
WE'VE BEEN TO THE BORDER.
>> Reporter: YOU HAVEN'T BEEN
TO THE BORDER.
>> AND I HAVEN'T BEEN TO EUROPE.
[LAUGHS]
I DON'T UNDERSTAND THE POINT
THAT YOU'RE MAKING.
>> Tucker: THE POINT OF COURSE
IS THAT YOU HAVEN'T BEEN TO THE
BORDER, WHICH SHE DID NOT
UNDERSTAND.
AND SHE WAS EQUALLY BAFFLED AND
ENRAGED A FEW DAYS LATER WHEN A
REPORTER ASKED OF THE SAME
QUESTION.
WATCH.
>> I SAID I'M GOING TO GO TO THE
BORDER.
>> WHEN ARE YOU GOING TO THE
BORDER, VICE PRESIDENT?
>> THE ADMINISTRATION IS
ASKED -- I'M NOT FINISHED.
I SAID I'M GOING TO THE BORDER.
>> Tucker: I'M NOT FINISHED.
[LAUGHS]
A COLUMNIST AT
"THE NEW YORK POST" WHO WE ARE
HAPPY TO HAVE WITH US.
THIS IS NOT SOMEONE WHO WAS
PULLED OFF THE STREET TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS FROM NBC AND
UNIVISION, BOTH OF WHICH ARE
SLAVISHLY LOYAL TO THE BY THE
ADMINISTRATION PAIR THIS IS THE
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES WHO HAS A WHOLE
P.R. TEAM AROUND HER.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF RESPONSES
LIKE THAT?
>> HI, TOOK HER.
SHE'S OBVIOUSLY BEEN PREPPED
WITHIN AN INCH OF HER LIFE.
SHE'S HAD EXTENSIVE MEDIA
TRAINING ON THIS PARTICULAR
QUESTION BECAUSE THE MINUTE THAT
JOE BIDEN GAVE HER THAT POISON
CHALICE OF BEING THE
ADMINISTRATION'S A BORDER CZAR,
THAT WAS THE QUESTION AND WHEN
SHE TOOK THREE MONTHS TO GET TO
THE BORDER, OBVIOUSLY SHE WAS
GOING TO BE ASKED IT.
AND FOR HER BIZARRE AND BRITTLE
AND VERY INSECURE RESPONSES TO
THAT OBVIOUS QUESTION, WHICH
LESTER HOLT COULD NOT HAVE BEEN
MORE GENTLE WHEN HE ASKED THAT
QUESTION, IT WAS JUST WHEN SHE
OUTRIGHT SAID, I'VE BEEN TO THE
BORDER AND HE JUST STONED SAID,
ACTUALLY,
YOU HAVEN'T, THAT SHE THEN CAME
OUT WITH AN EVEN
MORE BIZARRE RESPONSE OF HAVING
NOT BEEN TO EUROPE AND SHE
COULDN'T UNDERSTAND.
OF COURSE SHE UNDERSTOOD AND THE
PROBLEM WITH KAMALA HARRIS IS
THAT SHE HAS COME UP IN
CALIFORNIA WHERE THE MEDIA IS
JUST UNQUESTIONINGLY SHOWERING
HER WITH PRAISE.
SHE EXPECTS THE MEDIA TO DO
THAT.
SHE DOESN'T EXPECT CHALLENGING
QUESTIONS AND SHE'S QUITE
AFFRONTED BY IT.
YOU SEE HER ATTITUDE, SHE GETS
VERY CHILLY AND SHE FEELS IT IS
A MORTAL OFFENSE THAT SHE IS
BEING ASKED A QUESTION THAT
DOESN'T ALLOW HER TO SHINE AND
SKATE THROUGH THESE DIFFICULT
IDEAS, LIKE PERHAPS THAT THERE
IS A PROBLEM AT THE BORDER, AND
I JUST THINK THAT SHE IS NOT
MATCH FIT AND I DON'T SEE HOW
SHE CAN BE BECAUSE I GUESS SHE
HAS NEVER EXERCISED THOSE
MUSCLES BEFORE BECAUSE ALL SHE
HAS EVER HAD BEFORE IS
ACCOLADES.
>> Tucker: THAT IS SUCH A WISE
POINT.
SHE ACTS LIKE SHE HAS BEEN
BETRAYED BY A FRIEND WHEN THE